(guitare acoustique folk)
- Il y a un tout
nouveau cueilleur dans
les champs de brocolis
des Jardins Paul Cousineau.
♪ ♪ ♪
Depuis début septembre,
une firme d'ingénierie
québécoise y teste son SAMI,
son Système agricole
multifonctionnel et intelligent.
JULIEN COUSINEAU, ingénieur
mécanique Jardins Paul Cousineau
- La machine,
elle répond aux exigences.
La vitesse puis sa précision,
c'est quand même excellent.
- Chaque bras robotisé
du SAMI devrait remplacer
un travailleur agricole.
ÉRIC LAPALME, prés.,
Lapalme Conception Mécanique
- J'ai grandi sur une ferme
puis j'ai récolté du brocoli
quand j'étais adolescent
plus qu'à mon tour.
Un cueilleur, c'est ni plus
ni moins des yeux, un cerveau,
des mains, un bras.
Donc, ce qu'on a ici,
c'est exactement ça.
- Pour construire sa machine,
Lapalme met ensemble
des équipements existants
qu'elle rend intelligents
grâce à des caméras
et un système de contrôle.
- L'intelligence artificielle
va reconnaître le brocoli.
Dans ce cas-ci, c'est
un brocoli... ça pourrait être
un autre légume, donc reconnaît
le brocoli, reconnaît
son diamètre, ses imperfections
et va déceler s'il est bon
à être récolté ou pas.
VINCENT LAMARRE, prof., Institut
de technologie agroalimentaire
- La robotisation en champ,
ça existe déjà, oui. Dans le cas
de la récolte pour des cultures
en rang, comme le brocoli ou des
fruits et légumes avec feuilles,
oui, c'est nouveau.
- La technologie permettra aussi
de répertorier les légumes
qui ne sont pas encore prêts
et de détecter les maladies
ou la présence d'insectes.
- Le système d'intelligence
artificielle va venir nous aider
aussi à faire des dépistages
que même parfois l'oeil va avoir
de la difficulté à voir
parce qu'on parcourt par
tout le champ nécessairement.
- Un SAMI avec huit robots
se vendra environ 1 million $.
Et le plus gros modèle,
avec 20 robots,
près de 2,5 millions.
- On a un payback de...
en bas de trois ans, quatre ans,
quelque chose comme ça. Donc,
au final, bien, c'est rentable.
Puis d'autant plus qu'on peut
récolte jour, soir, nuit, sur
l'heure du dîner, il prend
pas de pause, les dimanches.
- La main-d'oeuvre est difficile
à avoir. Donc, les robots,
c'est une belle alternative
pour remplacer du travail
long et répétitif, dans des
conditions qui sont extérieures
pas toujours faciles.
- Mais robotiser comporte
des risques financiers.
- On parle d'un gros montant.
Si on achète une machine
aujourd'hui, l'année prochaine,
les travailleurs, je les fais
venir, je les fais pas venir?
Si je les fais pas venir puis,
la machine, elle marche pas,
bien, je laisse les brocolis
au champ.
♪ ♪ ♪
SIMON BÉLANGER, dir., dév. des
affaires chez Lapalme Agtech
- Ce qu'on fait présentement,
c'est qu'on prend
la robotisation des usines
et on l'amène dans le champ.
Donc, faut s'attendre
des gouvernements qu'il y ait
des subventions au même niveau
que les usines.
- Lapalme espère conclure
ses premières ventes
dans le brocoli au cours
des prochains mois.
Et l'entreprise rêve déjà
d'étendre sa technologie
à plusieurs autres légumes.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, St-Constant.